[موسيقى]
نرحب بمشاهدين وبمستمعي مونتي كارلو
الدوليه نرحب ايضا بضيوف البرنامج الذين
تشاهدونهم على الشاشه ويمكنكم ان تتفاعلوا
مع ما يقولون على صفحتنا على فيسبوك او
على صفحه البرنامج على تويتر
في النقاش القوات الروسيه كثفت ضرباتها في
اكثر من مدينه في اوكرانيا ضربات تسببت في
سقوط ما لا يقل عن سته قتله قطع التيار
الكهربائي بسبب القصف فيزابوريجا وخيرسون
والفيف موسكو تقول ان الضربات هي بمثابه
رد على توغل لمن وصفتهم بمخرب اوكرانيين
فوق راضيها في الثاني من هذا الشهر هل
تسعى القوات الروسيه الى استعاده السيطره
عسكريا وماذا عن حجمي صمود القوات
الاوكرانيه سعيد بان يكون معي من موسكو
وهو دائما حاضر معنا ديمتري بريجا وهو
صحفي ومحلل سياسي سعيد بان يكون معنا من
كياب قسطنطين وهو باحث في العلاقات
الدوليه وسعيد دائما بان يكون معي من جناب
حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في
جامعه جنيف اهلا وسهلا بالضيوف قبل ان
نبدا نستمع الى ما قاله وزير الخارجيه
الروسي
السعودي
عن السياسه الخارجيه للاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزيف بورين
بالمئه
ولذلك يجب علينا كما تحدثنا بالامس تعزيز
قدرات اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن نفسها
وماذا قال امين عام حلف الناتو يانس
ستولتنبر عندما اكد بانه لا يجب ان نقلل
من شان روسيا
تستعرض ضد اوكرانيا ولكن شاهدنا خلال
الاسابيع والاشهر الماضيه معارك ضاريه حول
بخموت
وما نلاحظه هو ان روسيا تحشد المزيد من
القوات والعتاد وانها تحاول تعويض
افتقارها للحسم عن طريق زياده الكم لقد
عانوا من خسائر فادحه ولكن في نفس الوقت
لا يمكننا استبعاد السقوط بخموت في الايام
المقبله
اي نقطه تحول في الحرب لكنه يشير الى اننا
لا يجب ان نقلل من شان روسيا
ينبغي ان نواصل دعم اوكرانيا
فنفهم كلام ستولت لا يجب ان نقلل من شان
روسيا هل هناك ادراك بان روسيا غيرت
استراتيجيتها العسكريه في الفتره الاخيره
من خلال تكثيف الضربات واستخدام اسلحه
مختلفه عما استخدمته في البدايه
مساء الخير تحياتي لكم وللساده المشاهدين
ولضيوفكم الكرام اعتقد بكل تاكيد
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه تتغير من وقت الى
وقت بعد استهداف الجسر في مضيق قرش في شبه
جزيره القرم بدات روسيا باستهداف العمق
الاوكراني ومحطات الكهرباء ومصانع للسلع
لصناعه الاسلحه التي هدفها الاساسي ضرب
القوات الروسيه واضح بان الان روسيا يعني
بدات بتكثيف ضرباتها على
مصانع اسلحه الاوكرانيه وايضا محطات
الكهرباء بعد توهل القوات الاوكرانيه الى
داخل العمق الروسي في مقاطعه برانسك والتي
جاء الرد على عليها باستهداف على العمق
الاوكراني روسيا الان في استراتيجياتها
تحاول استنزاف قدرات القوات الاوكرانيه
كما ايضا الطرف الاوكراني يحاول استنزاف
القدرات الروسيه في يعني في استمراره في
استهداف القوات الروسيه في مناطق عده
والاستنزاف الذين نراه الان في مدينه
والتي هناك معارك ضاربه
مهمه للقوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه القوات
الروسيه ايضا يعني سيطرت على شرق منطقه
مدينه باخموت وفق ما تتحدث عنه وساعه
الاعلام الروسيه قوات فاق سيطرت بالفعل
على شرقي مدينه طباخ الان المعارك تدور في
باك موت هناك اتهامات
يعني تتحدث عنه وسائل الاعلام
قائد القوات الاوكرانيه البريه الكسن
والذي يعني يتهمه البعض بانه يستنزف
القوات الاحتياط لدى القوات الاوكرانيه في
مدينه باكموت والتي بسببها قد تحدث مشاكل
في القوات الاوكرانيه يتم اخذ القوات من
يعني جبهات خارقه
من
المناطق الى باك موت ولذلك الان واضح بان
الطرفين يحاول استنزاف قدراتهم العسكريه
في هذه المنطقه
وحتى الان واضح بان روسيا تكثف من ضرباتها
ردا على توغل الاوكراني في العمق الروسي
قسطنطين يعني رغم كل ما نرى ونسمع في
الفتره الاخيره من تكثيف الضربات نوع من
القلق حتى لدى الغربه مع ذلك الرئيس
فولوديمير يقول لا سنصمد وسننواجه رغم ان
الامكانيات والوضع تغير نسبيا الارض خاصه
في بخموت مع دخول فاجنر على الخط
نعم
استراتيجيه الاوكرانيه لا تتغير لان
اول استعاده السيطره على جميع المناطق
المحتله وبذلك
الاستراتيجيه الدفاعيه لباحث تهدف استنزاف
القوات الروسيه بقدر الامكان
قال بان المدينه ستسقط خلال ايام نعم هناك
الكثير من التقديرات المتضاربه
هذا هذا تصريف النخيل من وهناك الامريكان
الذين قالوا بان مدينه قد يمكن ان تصمد
لعده اسابيع على الاقل
بالاضافه ان هناك يعني تحجزات لدي طرفين
ولدي طرف الاوكراني لمواجهه الاثاره في
الروسي انا اريد ان اشير الى نقطه مهمه
النقطه مهمه ان روسيا تستخدم
لتبرر هجماتها على البنيه تحتها
الاوكرانيه بتواغل بما يسمى بالتواغل
الاوكراني في الروسي الذي هو ليس صحيح
لانه هناك مجموعه متتاويين الروس الذين
تحملوا بمسؤوليه بهذا التوغل وكيف يمكن ان
تبرر
المعتاد
اي انشطه الدفاعيه داخل اوكرانيا للقيام
بالعمليه الارهابيه على منشات منشات
المدنيه طيب هذا التوغل في الثاني من هذا
الشهر حصل لم يحصل
بكل تاكيد وفق وسائل اعلام الروسيه وبعدها
حتى حدث خطاب للرئيس الروسي الذي راى بان
هذا التوغل هو محاوله ارهابيه يعني تدخل
في الشؤون الداخليه روسيا وايضا استهداف
الاراضي الروسيه واضح بان هذا التوغل الان
له ردز روسي عليه وبسببه يتم الان استهداف
العمق الاوكراني والمحطات الكهرباء ومصانع
اسلحه الاوكرانيه هذا التوغل يعني هو كان
عمل
ارهابي كما وصفه الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين هو توهل استهدف المدنيين في هذه
المنطقه كما ايضا تحدث عنه الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين فواضح بان الان الطرفان
يحاولان يحاولان استهداف العمق الطرف
الاوكراني منذ ايام
كان هناك حديث باسقاط طائره مسيره في ريف
موسكو وايضا في مدن مختلفه في العمق
الروسي فال الاوكراني بدا يستهدف العمق
الروسي ولذلك هناك الان هذا الرد القاسي
على هذا الاستهداف لاستهداف العمق
الاوكراني الاستراتيجيه واضحه كل طرف
يحاول الان ان يسبب مشاكل
للداخل يعني الطرف الاوكراني يستهدف العمق
الروسي والطرف الروسي يرد على هذا
الاستهداف باستهداف العمق الاوكراني
قسطنطين يعني عندما نرى ما نرى اليوم
وكاننا عدنا الى نقطه الصفر لان في فتره
معينه التركيز على مدينه بخموت القصف الان
طالع
يعني اكثر من الخرسون طلع اكثر من مدينه
في اوكرانيا يعني الضرب او توجيه الضربات
في كل الاتجاهات يدخل في اطار استراتيجيه
للضغط برايك للوصول الى حل ام ان مساله
الحسم اصبح الضروريه للجانب الاوكراني
وايضا للجانب الروسي
صراحه يعني اولا اريد ان
ملاحظات ملاحظه ملاحظه التوهل الاوكراني
الى المملك الروس فاذا نتابع منطق الرئاسه
الروسيه
ما ما هو الذي قام به قامت به روسيا في 24
فبراير
2022 لما يكون هذا التوغلا داخل عمق
الاوكراني بدون التبرير وماذا قامت بروسيا
في 2014 بتوغل ما يسمى بالتواغل داخل شبه
جزيره القرم المستقل او داخل
منطقه اما بالنسبه لاستهداف ومختلف
المناطق ليس لدي اي يعني تبرير او يعني
تفسير لهذه الضربات لان روسيا
تاكدت بان استراتيجيه استهداف المنشات
الطاقه او منشات المدنيه في الشتاء لم
لم تؤدي الى الاهداف
لم تؤدي الى تحقيق اهدافها لان الهدف
الرئيسي لدي الطرف الروسي كان اجبار طرف
الاوكراني الى جلوس على طاوله المفاد
طاوله المفاوضات الذي لم يحصل بعض وسوف لا
يحصل نتيجه لهذه الضربات الاخيره وبالرغم
انها كانت ربما اوصى نتاك منذ اكتوبر
العامل الماضي
يعني لم
تتضرر البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه بنفس
الدرجه فهناك كان هناك بعض الانقطاعات
الكهرباء في بعض المناطق الاوكرانيه ولكن
استعاد الكهرباء في معظم منها
في غضون الساعات فلذلك
ربما تستخدم روسيا هذه التكتيكات لتبرير
او يعني
لتبرير او تقديم هذه الصوره او تقديم هذه
هذه انتقامها الى الشعب الشعب الروسي او
المجتمع الروسي عن طريق وصايي الاعلامها
اما بالنسبه للاهداف الحقيقيه ولم تؤدي
الى اي اي منها
طيب حسني عبيدي واخيرا اراك بالصوت
والصوره يبدو ان التشويت بدا قبل هذا
الاجتماع المقرر يوم الاثنين في جناب
التشويش على الشبكه اقصد وحرصته على ان
اراك بشكل جيد صوتا
وصوره اهلا بك يعني هناك تغيير في
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه في الفتره الاخيره
من خلال استهداف اكثر من مدينه وكاننا
عدنا الى البدايه يعني هل هذا يدخل في
اطار استراتيجيه معينه ام الان روسيا تريد
ان تقول نحن جيش الروسي مع مجموعه فاجنر
على استعداد لحسم هذه المعركه
اهلا بك يا استاذ توفيق وضيوفك وللمشاهدين
الكرام انا اعتقد فعلا بان هناك تحول في
الاستراتيجيه يعني الروسيه وكانها تقول
تساعد سنصعد الان الخيار كما تعلم كان على
قضيه انه سيكون هناك تململ داخل اوروبا
وداخل الغرب بصفه عامه وان في النهايه لن
يكون هناك ذلك الدعم العسكري الذي كان
منشود الذي كان الذي لم تكن تريده روسيا
بفضل التعويل على فصل الشتاء تعويلها كذلك
على نقص الامدادات
التعميل حتى على ازمات اجتماعيه لم تحصل
في النهايه استطاعت كل الدول الاوروبيه
السيطره والتقويض تقريبا ببعض المظاهرات
وبعض حتى الاحزاب السياسيه التي رفضت اي
مساعده عسكريه الان تقريبا كل الدول وافقت
ان المهمه وافقت على تسليح روسيا بالعكس
على حتى
تصليح اوكرانيا باسلحه مهمه جدا وبالتالي
ما لم يبقى اعتقد لرو سيا الا من خيار
ثاني اولا هو التصعيد
اوكرانيا اصبحت غير امنه يعني
تذكرا حتى كانت العديد من السفارات او جزء
من السفارات كان موجود في تركيب على اساس
انها المدينه الاكثر امنا ثم اعتقد ما يح
في جورجيا مهم جدا ما يحدث في بلدان مهم
جدا وهو ان في النهايه يعني روسيا يمكن
لها ان تحرك اوراق جديده محيطه باوكرانيا
يمكن فعلا ان تزعج قبل كل شيء رئيسكي ثم
كذلك ان تشتت حتى المجهود الغربي اذا
استطعت وانت سؤالك كان مهم حول قضيه هل في
النهايه خرقوف مهمه ام لا عندما طرح
السؤال من قبل سينان على رئيس قال لا
خركوف مهمه جدا لانها في النهايه ستفتح
الطريق امام روسيا في حين انا الحلف
الاطلس يقول ولانه لا يريد في النهايه ان
يصور المشهد وكانه ماساوي قال بانها ليست
مهمه لن تغير من المشهد الاستراتيجي مما
يعني انه ربما هناك بعض الخلافات في وجهات
النظر بين الدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا وبين
اوكرانيا لكن من المؤكد ان في روسيا هناك
تغير هناك تحول جديد والرئيس بوتين كان
دائما يقول باننا لم نزج في النهايه او لم
نقول كلمتنا بما يعني فعلا بان الايام
المقبله ستكون ايام صعبه جدا لن تحصل
الامر كما كل الدول الغربيه السفارات
الغربيه هنا كانت تقول بان شهر فبراير
سيشهد حسب للمعركه في اوكرانيا في النهايه
ان يعود الى البدء طيب مثل ما قال حسن
عبيدي
الامور لم تحسم بعد ولكن هذه الرساله التي
يريد ان يوصلها فلاديمير بوتين في النهايه
من الصعب ان نقراها بشكل جيد للغرب قادر
على ان يقراه ولا من يتابع قادر على ان
يقرا ما هي الرساله التي يريد ان يوصلها
يعني اولا لكي تحسم المعركه بشكل كامل كما
تحدث حتى
رئيس شركه فاجنر بان يجب ان يعني تحدث
معارك الى سنه من سنه ونصف الى سنتين يعني
هو في تصريحات الاخيره تحدث للسيطر على
مقاطعه بشكل كامل تحتاج القوات الروسيه من
سنه ونصف الى سنتين اما الطريق الاخر
للسيطره الكامله على كافه المناطق او حتى
بشكل كامل على اوكرانيا يحتاج الى تعبئه
عامه ووضع الاقتصاد الروسي على طريق
في حاله حرب في حاله التجهيز العسكري كما
كان في الحرب العالميه الثانيه عندما واجه
الاتحاد السوفيتي المانيا النازيه فالوضع
الحالي ايضا يعني الان هناك تقدم تكتيكي
للقوات الروسيه سيطره قوات الروسيه على
السوليدار بعد معارك طويله ايضا الان
السيطره على باك بوت هناك تقدم تكتيكي
للقوات الروسيه كل طرف يحاول استنزاف
القدرات العسكريه الطرف الاوكراني لا
يتحدث عن عدد القتلى من القوات الاوكرانيه
كان في حتى في باقي متوفر وهو يخفي اعداد
القتلى هناك اعداد كبيره لقتل الجنود
الاوكرانيين ايضا لا ننسى بان قاعده
القوات البريه هذه المعركه في له يعني
تعتبر انتصار له اذا لم يستطيع ان ينجز
شيء في باخموت ولن تضبط القوات الاوكرانيه
فقاعده قوات البريه الاوكرانيه سوف يكون
له نوع من الخساره الشخصيه اذا ما سيطرت
القوات الروسيه على
انهزمت القوات الاوكرانيه في وجه القوات
الروسية
فلذلك الان كل طرف يحاول استعمال
استراتيجيات مختلفه واضح بان الطرفان الان
ذاهبان الى التصعيد كما حدث في السابق اذا
ما استمرت القوات الاوكرانيه استهداف
العمق الروسي فسوف يكون هناك رد قاسي
للقوات الروسيه روسيا حتى الان لم تستعمل
كافه كل قواتها او كل القدرات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا حتى الان كثير من الاسلحه التي
لم يتم استعمالها ولم تحدث هناك تعبئه
جزئيه
يعني
تستطيع ان تسيطر على اوكرانيا لكن لما لما
تشوف انه في بقى موت صعوبه كبيره يعني انه
انت ثاني قوه في العالم يعني تستعين بقوه
خاصه يجب ان نذكر بان الرئيس بوتين في كل
تصريحاته يقول مع الناس حتى علاقه ليس لها
هذا اصلا يعني لا يمكن ان لا تخضع
المساءله القانونيه فاذا كانت هناك صعوبه
يعني توفر للقوات الروسيه بالاستيلاء على
بالخبوط في يعني في في زمن قصير جدا فكيف
يمكن يعني كل مصير المدن الاخرى وهي صعوبه
كبيره يعني ربح او خطر في اوكرانيا نضعت
كما قال اليوم في مجله انه فعلا يعني
الرئيس الروسي اخذ القرار اكثر سوءا منذ
وصوله الى سلطه لانه عدم السيطره على
بقبول من قبل روسيا يدل فعلا بانها لا
يمكن ان تبسط سيطرتها على باقي المدن
الاوكرانيه حتى في حاله يعني نجاحها
عسكريه طيب قسنطينه جيليدين تعليقا على
كلام حسني عبيدي في هذا المجال وما كتب
ايضا في المجله الفرنسي هل انتم احسنتم في
اوكرانيا استغلال هذه الفكره لماذا استعان
الجيش الروسي في النهايه بيفاجنر وكل ما
قيل وخاصه انتقادات رئيس مجموعه فاغنر
للجيش الروسي هل احسنتم استعمال ما حصل من
كلام
صراحه مجموعه كانت موجوده في اوكرانيا
ليست منذ عسليه قليله ولكن منذ فتره طويله
وكانت تستخدم في بعض العمليات ذات الاهميه
الكبرى لدى
القوات الروسيه وفي نفس الوقت هناك خلافات
علميه بين هذه المجموعه
رئاسه وزاره يعني قياده وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
فصراحه
من المعروف ان مجموعه
مستوى تدريبهم ربما اعلى من متوسط الجيش
الروسي فلذلك هناك اهميه كبيره على هذه
هناك يعني انتباه كبير لهذه المجموعه ولكن
القوات القوات الاوكرانيه صراحه لا تفرق
كثيرا بين مجموعه واي وحدات من الجيش
الروسي النظامي معتبرا معتبرا انها كلها
اهداف
قانونيه لتدمير
ولذلك يعني هي تواصل استراتيجياتها بهذه
الطريقه
دائما تعليقا على كلام حسن عبيدي هل هناك
نيه لدى الروس للعب ورقه دول الجوار اقصد
بشكل خاص مولدافيا وجورجيا
يعني اولا هناك تنافس بين قوات سياسيه
داعمه لروسيا وقوه سياسيه رافضه للسياسه
الروسيه وهي تريد ان تكون هذه الدول ضمن
الاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا جورجيا الان اذا
هناك نوع من التنافس بين الاحزاب السياسيه
مثلا الحزب الذي كان لرئيس
السابقاشفيلي والذي كان سياسات دعم
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وكان يريد ان تكون اوكرانيا
جورج ان تكون جورجيا اوروبيه واحزاب اخرى
داعمه لان تكون هناك علاقات مع روسيا ايضا
نفس الشيء فيه كازاخستان في مولدوفا
وغيرها من الدول هذا التنافس هو واضح الان
وبكل تاكيد ستستفيد يمكن هناك نوع من
الاستفاده لروسيا من هذا التنافس السياسي
الذي يحدث في هذه الدول هناك حقبه وهناك
جزء من السياسيين الذين يريدون ان يكونوا
جزء من التحالف الروسي او ما كانت عليه
روسي في السابق
اقصد الاتحاد السوفيتي هم داعبون لسياسات
الاتحاد السوفيتي في السابق كانوا يدعمون
سياسه حادث والان هم يريدون ان يكون نوع
من التحالف مع روسيا لذلك هذا التنافس ان
كان في مولدوفا في جورجيا وفي كازاخستان
ايضا كانت شهدت حاله من التغيير حاله
تغيير سياسي من يعني وصلوا للسلطه من نظام
سياسي داعمه واقرب لروسيا الى اصول
السياسي الى السلطه يعني السياسات وان
كانت حياديه او اقرب لدول اتحاد الاوروبي
والموقف الغربي ممثله بالرئيس الحالي
والسياسه السابقه التي كانت اقرب لروسيا
والتوجه الروسي فواضح بان كما قلت الان
العالم مقبل على تغييرات كثيره
وروسيا يعني تحاول بناء تحالف سياسي ولكن
حتى الواضح بان هناك بعض المشاكل التي
تواجهها روسيا في تحالف السياسي التي
تحاول بنا وهذا ما رايناه في يعني في
في الامم المتحده عندما صوت دول مختلفه
لصالح القرار لصالح فرض العقوبات ومزيد من
العقوبات على روسيا القرار الذي كان ضد
روسيا والدول التي لم تدعم القرار
وهذا الشيء يعني واضح حتى من خطابات
الرئيس الروسي الذي
يحاول تغيير التوجه السياسي لروسيا التوجه
الذي كان اقرب
للغربشيه الروسيه التي كانت دائما للغرب
والتي كانت تضع اموالها في البنوك
الاوروبيه الى التوجه نحو الشرق ونتوجه
نحو دعم الاقتصاد الروسي والعمل على بناء
اقتصاد مستقل عن الدول الغربيه
طيب حسن عبيد الان بما انك في جنيف يعني
انت هل تتساءل مثلا عما سيجري يوم الاثنين
المقبل عندما يتعلق الامر بسله الغذاء
التي هي اوكرانيا هناك قلق كبير لدى
المجتمع الدولي فيما يتعلق بهذا الاتفاق
لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه يعني هناك
استعداد للقاء او سيجري هذا اللقاء يوم
الاثنين في جنيف جنيف التي احتضنت العديد
من اللقاءات في صراعات اخرى لحل الازمه
نفكر في هذا الموضوع ولكن الموضوع الاخر
كيفيه وقف الحرب غير مطروح حاليا
سؤالك مهم لانه في النهايه روسيا منذ
الموقف الروسي على اقل موقف وزاره
الخارجيه لانه وزير الخارجيه ايناس اقرب
كثير من الموقف الامريكي منه الى الموقف
موقف العديد من الاحزاب التي تريد الحفاظ
على الحياد
كانت تحت وقال سوري لم تعد منذ اليوم
المفارقه انه في قضيه الحبوب اول من سارعي
للاتفاق من العقد الاجتماعي الموافقه على
اجتماع والقول بانه سيعقد بجنيف هي روسيا
وهذا اعتقد بعطى تقريبا مستمر وهو حرص
روسيا دائما على انها في النهايه منفتحه
على الدبلوماسيه متعدده الاطراف لان
عقيلتها الان التي تحاول ان تسويقها خاصه
لدول الجنوب وهي انها محور الدبلوماسيه
المتحده الاطراف ان روسيا مع الصين تحاول
ان تحارب من اجل هذا في النهايه التقوقع
جديد او محاوله الولايات المتحده ان تكون
الدوله المهيمنه الاساسيه صحيح الحبوب
لانه في النهايه فيروز يخدم روسيا كثيرا
هذه الحرب روسيا مستعده فعلا حتى ان اولا
ان التجديد بهذا الاتفاق وكان يمكن ان
تعقد الاجتماع في تركيا وفي نفس الوقت هي
تريد
كذلك ان تعطي هذا الوجه بانه على اساس
انها فعلا مع الدبلوماسيه وليست ضد
الدبلوماسيه واذا كان من هو فقط اوكرانيا
والدول الغربيه وعطفا على اجابه
جديده على قضيه هناك مشكل كبير الان يقع
في الغرب يعني تقريبا الاموال الاموال
المج
نه الاكثر من 560 مليار دولار هذه فقط ثم
اعلن عنها هناك حديث جدي حول مصادره هذه
الاموال لم تقبل لحد الان البنوك او الدول
الغربيه على ان تحول هذه الاموال من اجل
في النهايه شراء الاسلحه المهمه وارسالها
لاوكرانيا لكن انا اعتقد هناك تدمر كبير
الان هي تحت المراقبه ولا اعتقد ستفضل في
النهايه علاقات مع اوزباكستان ومع غينيا
وموريتانيا وان تترك في النهايه الريفيرا
الفرنسيه وتترك كدايا الدول الغربيه هاي
مشكله كبيره يعني ولذلك يعني ما قلنا حول
مستقبل بوتين بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه او حتى
بين الحرب الاوكرانيه مرهون فعلا بعلاقاته
في الداخل وكذلك سيروره هذه الحرب طيب
ضيفي من اكياف انتم ايضا بحاجه الى هذا
الاتفاق لانكم في هذه الحرب بحاجه الى
تمويل والحبوب لا يمكن ان تظل موجوده في
اوكرانيا دون تصديرها ولكن المفتاح يظل في
جيب موسكو
ليس في جيب بوسكو يعني مئه بالمئه
نعم يعني كما نتذكر في شهر اكتوبر او
سبتمبر عمل الماضي انسحبت روسيا من هذه
الاتفاق لمده يومين وبعدين انضمت الى هذه
الاتفاق مره مره اخرى فحتى اذا انسحبت
روسيا مره مره ثانيه
الاسبوع المقبل الاتفاق مازال ساريه
المفعول لانه ليس هناك انتفاق ثلاثي وهناك
اتفاق بين اوكرانيا والامم المتحده وتركيا
واتفاق ثاني بين تركيا وروسيا
يعني لتضمين هذه هذه الامدادات حتى اذا
انسحبت روسيا من الاتفاق مع تركيا
الاتفاق بين اوكرانيا والامم المتحده
وتركيا
سوف سوف يستمر فلذلك
تقنيا يمكن مواصله التصدير الحبوب حتى
بدون مشاركه روسيه ولكن في حال الانسحاب
من هذه الاتفاقيه روسيا سوف تتحمل
بالمسؤوليه تعطيل هذه الاتفاق او
اي يعني تهديدات امنيه التي تواجهها السفن
الاوكرانيه او تغضى لها السفن الاوكرانيه
الاتيه من الموانئ الاوكرانيه باتجاه
تركيا روسيا ستكون مسؤوله عن اي اي خلل
امني فلذلك انا اعتقد انه اتفاقيه بشكل او
باخر ستستمر رغم ان روسيا ما زالت وارق
تنفيذ هذه الاتفاقيه بقدر امكانها يعني عن
طريق مواقله
تفتيش السفن الاوكرانيه في الموانئ
التركيه ولكن هذه هذه اتفاقيه سوف سوف
تصلح للكثير من الدول ليست لاوكرانيا
فاخره فلذلك انا اعتقد ان الدول العالم
الثالث دول افريقيا ودول دول الشرق الاوسط
بالذات سوف تضغط بقدر الامكانها على روسيا
لكي تستمر مشاركتها في هذه الاتفاقيه
روسيا ليست لاعبه اساسيه في هذا الاتفاق
روسيا تبقى لها دور المهم لاخراج
لاخراج السفن الممتلئه بالحبوب من الموانئ
الاوكرانيه اذا لم يتم الاتفاق مع روسيا
سوف يكون هناك مشاكل تواجه الموانئ
الاوكرانيه لاخراج الحبوب منها واعتقد
روسيا سوف تبقى يعني لها دور المهم في
اتفاقيه الحبوب نتذكر في السابق تركيا
كانت لعبه دورا مهما في الوساطه بين روسيا
واوكرانيا في اتفاقيه الحبوب واعتقد بان
لو خرجت روسيا من اتفاقيه الحبوب سوف تجد
اوكرانيا يعني تواجه اوكرانيا مشاكل في
اخراج هذه الحبوب من الموانئ الاوكرانيه
طيب حسن عبيدي بعد كل هذه الفتره بعد كل
هذه الانتقادات بعد كل هذه الادانات بعد
كل هذه التهديدات بملاحقه روسيا بتهمه
جرائم جرائم حرب تظل موسكو لها علاقات في
العالم العربي وراينا ذلك من خلال وزير
زياره وزير الخارجيه السعودي من الاطراف
الاخرى هل هذا ما تعول عليه روسيا على
الاقل في محاوله ايصال رسالتها
يمكن القول بان روسيا في النهايه استطاعت
فعلا ان تحافظ على نوع من لا اقول تحالف
لكن هناك استجابه من العديد من الدول
الاساسيه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه هناك
دول خليجيه دوله الامارات العربيه وهي
دوله مهمه كذلك الجزائر العديد من الدول
ما يحدث الان مع الصين يعني مهم جدا يعني
بالنسبه الامريكيه لو طالع الاعلام
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده الامريكيه روسيا
روسيا ليست تهديد يعني موضوعي مباشر وانما
هي الصين
تصريحات الاخيره الصينيه يعني يعني تم
التقاطها بسرعه من قبل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اذا استطاعت روسيا فعلا كما
الان تلوح الصين ان تكسب الصين عسكريا
واقتصاديا فهذه معذره بالنسبه لقضيه ايران
قضيه الملف النووي لنقل عربيا وافريقيا
صحيحا التصويت كان تصويت اغلبيه لجمعيه
العامه المتحده لكن كما تعلم ان الدول
العربيه عارفه جدا والافريقيه انها في
النهايه تصوت امتناعا او بنعم لكن في
نهايه تصويت الجمعيه الجمعيه العامه كده
لن يكون لديه ماطور يعني اي اثر وهناك
تفاهم من قبل من قبل روسيا وهو الامر الذي
تخشاه كل الدول الغربيه ولذلك يعني الرئيس
ماكرون كما كما لاحظت قام بهذه الزياره
لانه يعلم جيدا بان هناك فعلا مناطق نفوذ
مهمه
وسؤال يعني هناك ربط يعني سؤالك حول قضيه
اجتماع حول الحبوب وكذلك لماذا لماذا لم
يكون هناك اجتماع حول الازمه الاوكرانيه
هاي المشكله يعني في النهايه لماذا هذا كل
الوقت الضائع
الموظفين
بناء او ممكن البناء على اتفاقيه الحبوب
في النهايه اتفاقيه الحبوب اذا استمرت
يعني سنؤمن العديد من الموانئ الموانئ وما
ومحيط الموانئ وبالتالي يمكن في النهايه
ان في النهايه ان نصدر هذه الاتفاقين صح
التعبير ونعمها على اشياء اخرى في
اوكرانيا لان هناك عجز كبير لكن للاسف انا
اعتقد كل هذه المقاربات
الجزئيه والمرحليه لا يمكن لها ان تصل الى
نتيجه ما دام هناك دول الكبرى من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه واعتقد اوكرانيا في
النهايه يعني كدوله تابعه للغربه واصبح
مستقبلها مرهون بالدول الغربيه يجب فعلا
ان تفكر في قضيه ما بعد هذه الحرب
والتفكير له الان لان هناك تغييب كامل
يعني تصريحات تدل فعلا بانه ليس لا يمكن
له ان يقوم باي تصريح حول الحرب
الاوكرانيه ومع هذا التصعيد الاخير ففعل
هناك مخاوف كبيره على مسار السلم الذي
يمكن مسار الحرب الذي ان يتبدد الى مناطق
اخرى داخل اوروبا طيب قسطنطين نريدك ايضا
ان ترد على ما قاله حسني عبيدي ومع انه
الرئيس الاوكراني
اعتقد انه الوحيد الذي حصل على اكبر
المنابر عالميا كي يوصل رساله اوكرانيا
ولكن مع ذلك العديد من الدول تظل تفضل
البقاء على الحياد وعدم مسانده اوكرانيا
في هذا الموضوع ما رايك
نعم هناك
موقف موقف روسي قوي لدي الدول العربيه
وبعض دول الاسيويه والامريكا اللاتينيه
التي
تفضلت البقاء على موقف الحيادي
ربما ربما متوقع
تخفيض النفوذ الامريكيه في العالم في
العالم الخارجي الذي ربما يزعج الكثير من
الدول التي ارسلت يعني التي
صرح مسؤولا عن ذلك بشكل او باخر ولكن
اوكرانيا كما قلت تواصل الجهود الاعلاميه
جهود دبلوماسيه
اقناع قاعده الدول العربيه والكثير من
الدول الاخرى لتغيير مواقفهم فهناك كما
كما نقول الصراع الميداني في المعارك
والصراع الدبلوماسي والصراع الاقتصادي
فيما يخص العقوبات ومصادره الاموال
الروسيه فهناك الحرب
تسير على عده الجبهات
اوكرانيا سوف لا تتنازل عن نياتها لاقناع
هذه الدول لتغيير مواقفها طيب ولكن
ابتعدنا كل البعد عن المسار السلمي
اكيد
الخيار غير مطروح اطلاقا
المسار السلمي بمعنى الجلوس على طاوله
المفاوضات واعتراف بضم الاراضي الاوكرانيه
هذا مستحيل لان ليس بسبب ان اوكرانيا
لديها دعم الغربي لكن اذا اعترفت العالم
بالضم الاراضي الاوكرانيه بشكل غير
القانوني بشكل ارهابي
دعنا نقول سوف تكون هذه السابقه خطيره
للعالم للعالم كله وخاصه للمناطق اللاني
فيها خلافات بين الدول مثل الشرق الاوسط
اذا اذا اذا تم اعتراف ضم روسيا للاراضي
الاوكرانيه فيمكن لاي دوله كبيره في اي
منطقه ضم المناطق الحدوديه والمناطق دول
دول المجاوره سوف تؤدي الى هروب وخلافات
اكثر بكثير من ما يحدث الان في هذه
المناطق وخاصه
لكن تاريخ
الحروف لدينا مثال مهم يعني عفوا هو قضيه
مثلا السابقه
وبطائره وذهب الى دايتون الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وبعد ذلك وضع
يعني العديد من النزاعات اذا طرحت قضيه
مثلا محاكمه مباشره وقضيه الشروط قبل
الدخول في موضات من الصعب لانه اصلا من
شرط المفاوضات ان لا تكون هناك شروط
تعجيزيه او شروط مسبق لنتفاوض على تلك
الشروط فهذه القضيه يعني في النهايه يعني
وتسبيح كذلك الجزء القضائي القانوني
المساءله قبل الدخول حتى في مفاوضات
سياسيه سيينصف المسار السياسي وسيزيد في
النهايه من عمر اي ازمه وهذه الدروس
تعلمناها من العديد من ازمات سواء في
اوروبا او كذلك العديد من مناطق الاخر
للاسف
لك رد ضيف من كيف
نعم مهما كانت هذه اسس القانونيه او اي
تحذيرات القانونيه لقياده الروسيه كيف
يمكن تنفيذها لان روسيا دوله النوويه ولا
لا تتبع للقوانين الدوليه اذا ما تريده
فلذلك
حتى اذا كانت هناك اطر قانونيه وربما دور
الامم المتحده والياء المتحده اكثر فعلت
كيف يمكن تنفيذ اي قرار ملاحقه قانونيه او
اي محكمه دوليه ضد مثلا القياده الروسيه
لا هناك اليات لذلك نظرا
للتوافر
الاسلحه النوويه فلذلك على اوكرانيا ان
تستمر
صراعها وعلى العالم الحضاري
الوقوف الى جانب اوكرانيا لكي
تستمر يستمر النظام العلاقات الدوليه كما
هو عليه الان
حتى الذين لم يدعوكم يعني متحضرين يعني
موقف صحيح موقف الرباحيات ايجابي لكنهم
كذلك
يعني ضيفي من موسكو الورقه الصينيه التي
اقترحت يمكن ان نقول انها طويت قبل ان
تفتح
لا اعتقد ذلك الصيد بكل تاكيد لديها
السياسات مختلفه عن السياسه الروسيه حتى
في المقترح الصيني الذي تحدث عن موضوع
السلام بين روسيا واوكرانيا اوكرانيا يعني
الصين تحترف سياده اوكرانيا ولديها سياسه
مختلفه اذا ضم الاراضي التي ضمتها روسيا
وفق الاستفتاء الذي حدث فيها وواضح بان
السياسه الصينيه تحاول التحفظ في كثير من
المواضيع مثلا موضوع حتى ارسال
التكنولوجيا او الشرائح الالكترونيه عندما
بدا الغرب يضغط على الصين الصين بدات يعني
لا ترسل الشرائح الالكترونيه لروسيا يعني
نزل مستوى ارسال التكنولوجيات الى روسيا
الى يقارب اربعين بالمئه
بسبب الضغوطات الغربيه على الصين اذا
الصين تحاول الحفاظ على علاقتها مع الغرب
لان الغرب هو يدعم الصين يدعم الاقتصاد
الصيني وهناك علاقات قويه مع الصين
للشركات الامريكيه تستفيد من السوق الصيني
تستفيد من يعني المصانع الموجوده في الصين
اذا الصين هي لديها نوع من التحفظ نوع من
السياسه التي تحاول بكل تاكيد بناء
علاقاتها مع روسيا وتحاول ان تدعم روسي في
مواقفها في وجه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في الامم المتحده وحتى في حتى
في الملف السوري او غيره من الملفات نتذكر
الصين كانت دائما تدعم روسيا في المتحده
وايضا يجب ان نفهم بان هناك ازدواجيه في
المعايير في السياسه الغربيه عندما نتحدث
مثلا عن الملف السوري باراك اوباما كان
دائما يهدد الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
بخطوط الحمر ولكن هذه الخطوط لم تحدث ولم
يتغير شيء في الملف السوري ايضا الان
الغرب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه رئيس
امريكا يهدد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
يتحدث عن خطوط الحمر يتحدث عن الضغوطات
والعقوبات ولكن هذه العقوبات لم تغير من
الموقف الداخلي او من الحقبه او من يعني
من الموقف السياسيين في الداخل الروسي
الرئيس الروسي ايضا لم يتغير موقفه الغرب
استيقظ متاخرا بان الرئيس الروسي الذي
مربوط انه وليس ليس صديق للغرب وليس صديق
للسياسات الغربيه في كثير من الامور يعني
حتى دائما الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
طاقه الغربي بموضوع المثليه التقط الغربي
موضوع القيم الغربيه وهو يرى بان قيم
روسيا مختلفه عن القيم الغربيه في ملفات
كثيره الغرب استيقظ متاخرا ايضا حتى يعني
استيقظ لان بدات الحرب تطوق او بدات الحرب
اصبحت الحرب قريبه من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي قبل كانت هناك الصراع بين روسيا
وجورجيا ايضا العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
سوريا الغرب كان يحاول دائما يرسل رسائل
تهديد لروسيا ولكن هذه يعني الرسائل بدات
الان تتغير والموقف كان دائما يعني مزدوج
المعايير لدى الدول الغربيه اثناء عبيدي
الوساطه اما ان تكون غربيه او لا تكون
يعني هو الغرب واغراب يعني مش غرب واحد
يعني انت كما تعلم في اوروبا كانت يعني ما
زالت هناك اصوات يعني يعني حكيمه وعاقله
وقالت في البدايه انه لا يمكن لاوروبا ان
تفتح كما تقول كما تريد الولايات المتحده
جبهه الثانيه مع الصين النتيجه لم تسمع
هذه الاصوات همش كبير من قبل واشنطن الذي
يجب ان نعترف بانها تدير تقريبا لوحدها
الملف الملف الاوكراني سواء كدوله او كذلك
داخل الحلف الاطلسي الان عندما في النهايه
وصل
الامر اصبحت الصين تقول بانه في النهايه
بهذا التهديد تايوان زياره زياره منصب كما
تعلم بالاضافه الى العديد من الملفات
المثاره الان في الولايات المتحده ضد
الصين الصين تهذب بانها فعلا يمكن ان ان
تطعم علاقتها مع روسيا عسكريه الاقتصاديين
وانا اعتقد فعلا سيكون تحول كبير فلذلك
يعني انت قلت في بدايه برنامج انا لا من
الصعب فهم السياسه الصينيه انا اقول لك
انه من الصعب جدا كذلك فهم السياسه
الامريكيه خاصه مع الحلفاء الذين لا
يريدون فتح هذه الجبهه ستكون مكلفه جدا
لها باقتصاديا وسياسيا ولن تكون ولن تعود
بال بالفائده كذلك على الحرب في اوكرانيا
اما هل الوساطه ستكون غربيه ام لا
الان كما تعلم مصير اوكرانيا عسكريا
وسياسيين مرتبط جدا في بالغرب انه لابد
لابد ان يكون هناك على الاقل جاهزيه
جاهزيه دبلوماسيه مع الاستمرار في هذا
الضغط الضغط جاهزيه من قبل الغرب حتى حتى
نصل الى هذه المفاوضات وانا لا اعتقد ان
روسيا من مصلحته كذلك الاستمرار لانها
تعلم جدا بانها بان من الصعب على الغرب ان
يتقبل بوتين مستقبلا في حاله حتى انتصاره
وهو الشيء الغير مرجح من قبل كل الخبراء
العسكريه في الختام الموسكو
قسطنطينه وهو باحث في العلاقات الدوليه
وشكرا ايضا لحسن عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه
[موسيقى]